Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I finally had
a chance to watch Amazing Spider-Man 2 so
I wanted to do a review and talk about the
Sinister Six spinoff movies and the direct
Spider-Man sequels they’ve announced.
If you didn’t hear last year, they’re
basically creating their own Spider Move-Verse
at Sony just like Marvel has done.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do regular movie reviews for my favorite
sci fi, fantasy and comic book movies.
I even have a dedicated day for Marvel videos
on Tuesdays.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And let’s a dream of the day Marvel gets
the rights back to Spider-Man, so he can take
his rightful place in the Avengers.
Along with Wolverine.
So since there’s so much to talk about this
is how I’m going to do it.
I’ll do my review first, then talk about
the Sinister Six and the the post credits
scene.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Let’s start with what I loved the most about
the movie.
The actors.
Yes Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone are the
leads but I want to give some special attention
to Jamie Foxx and Dane Dehaan.
There was actually something funny I saw on
twitter.
A lot of the film critics I know were calling
the movie the best Batman Forever reboot ever.
They compared Jamie Foxx’s Electro to The
Riddler and Dane Dehaan to Tommy Lee Jones
emo Two-Face.
It’s not meant to make fun of them.
It’s just a funny meta way to think about
their performances.
He really is one of the best comedic character
actors out there.
The reason he was in Django Unchained was
because Will Smith didn’t want to play a
slave.
Jamie Foxx on the other hand is fearless when
it comes to putting himself into characters.
He’s not typecast like other A-List actors,
so he gets to have a lot more fun.
A la Electro and Sinister Six next.
Everytime I see a big movie like this I try
to figure out which scene they read in the
audition.
And I felt like Jamie Foxx did that Birthday
Cake scene in his apartment.
That’s the scene where you learn everything
you need to know about his character.
His ticks, the way he perceives himself and
the way he thinks about everyone else.
That scene was like a one-man play Jamie Foxx
could perform on Broadway.
It was one of my favorite non-action scenes.
Just him being crazy talking to himself.
I really did like Jamie Foxx’s Max Dillon
character better than Electro.
I don’t think we’ll see him again.
The Electro persona has basically taken over
by the end of the movie.
But let’s talk about Dane Dehaan.
Just like Jamie Foxx I really like the Harry
Osborn character before he became Green Goblin.
A lot of you may be seeing Dane Dehaan for
the first time.
We really didn’t get as much time with him
pre-transformation as we did with Jamie Foxx’s
character but my favorite Harry scene was
the board room.
Everyone in this room now works for Felicia.
I feel like enough time has passed that less
people thought of Jame’s Franco’s college
dropout Harry Osborn.
I totally enjoyed that Harry way way back.
But I think Dane Dehaan’s twist on the character
is a lot more interesting.
He does have the benefit of being a genius
this time around.
I’m not entirely sure why Norman Osborn
said he was wasting his potential.
That probably had something to do with him
traveling around the world dating supermodels
after school.
But my only big disappointment was that the
Oscorp executive became a fourth villain.
I don’t know about you guys, but I felt
like it would have been a lot more fun to
see an evil dark knight version of Harry Osborn.
Like the diametric opposite to Christian Bale’s
Batman.
In that scenario he would seize control of
the company and just use it to fund his private
war against the superheroes of all the sequels
and spinoffs.
They weren’t really clear about what his
status and wealth are after the movie.
He got fired from Oscorp by the board, but
I think he still owns the company.
So he’s still super rich, they just try
to lock him out of the building.
I don’t know how the sequels will treat
that, because at the end he’s locked up
in Ravencroft.
As for the main characters I always love Emma
Stone and given that they kind of spoiled
her fate in the trailer there really weren’t
any surprises from her character.
I do like that her Gwen Stacy got to be a
critical part of the solution.
But I still feel like she was wasted like
a lot of great actors get buried under these
giant movies.
Just like Scarlett Johansson in Avengers.
I feel like Winter Soldier was a good example
of a big comic book movie that gave an equal
role to the female lead.
So I feel like Sony could learn a lot from
from that.
We did see Felicia Hardy and even though she
was almost not even in the movie at all.
I’m expecting her to get an expanded Black
Cat role in the sequels.
In case you don’t remember, for a couple
months Shailene Woodley was playing Mary Jane
Watson.
They shot scenes with her and everything,
but ended up cutting her out of the movie.
Now that we’ve all seen it it’s easy to
understand why.
The story is just trying to do so many things
I’m glad they didn’t include more characters.
It would have been Spider-Man 3 all over again.
So let’s talk about the story.
There were a few things I really liked and
just a few things I had a big issue with.
So right off the bat going into movies like
this I try to remind myself that they’re
not made for me.
Remember the little kid that put the spider-man
pajamas on at the end of the movie.
That’s who this movie was made for.
It was made for little kids.
If you watch it with that in mind.
I feel like you’ll enjoy yourself a lot
more.
Don’t expect this to be the Dark Knight
or anything.
I love that they wanted to create a Spider
Movie Universe and I feel like Ravencroft
in addition to Oscorp Special Projects did
that.
We even know who the Six Characters are going
to be in Sinister Six.
I feel like those were the whole movie, you
could have called it Amazing Spider-Man 2,
Rise of The Sinister Six.
And nothing would have changed.
I am looking forward to the spinoffs.
But remember, those movies are also going
to be written for little kids in Spider-Man
pajamas.
The only issue I had with the story was the
amount of time the devoted to Spider-Man helping
non-essential characters.
Like the whole scene with him helping the
little kid with the windmill.
That scene was there because this is a movie
for little kids.
But the only other things that I felt were
tired were the jokes.
I feel like trying to do silly Spider-Man
humor was Sam Raimi’s thing.
And he is a master at that kind of humor.
Because that was something so many people
responded to from the original trilogy, I
felt like the producers were really quick
to try and force that into the Andrew Garfield
reboot.
But I’m just not a big fan of silly Andrew
Garfield.
I think he does a lot better when he’s doing
drama.
And just to talk about the action and camera
work.
I did like the creative improvements they
made to those first-person scenes.
Like the opening of the movie where you’re
seeing Spider-Man’s point of view.
The action scenes were good, but again Andrew
Garfield is a dramatic actor.
Not an action hero.
He’s not Chris Hemsworth.
And he doesn’t quite have the balance of
ridiculousness and sincerity that Robert Downey
Jr has, yet.
He’ll get there eventually.
He’s a great actor, so I’m interested
to see what the sequels look like.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what you thought of the movie?
Did you like the way they set up the spinoffs
and sequels?
And do you think they can create a Spider-Verse
without things getting too ridiculous?
Right now they’ve already confirmed Spider-Man
3 and 4 along with Sinister Six.
The next Spider Verse movie will be that third
sequel.
They’re supposed to start production on
Sinister Six early in 2015, so that might
not be out until late 2016 or spring 2017.
There is a Venom movie happening too, but
that’s not supposed to appear until around
Spider-Man 4.
Let’s talk about the Sinister Six lineup
and that X-Men Post Credits scene though.
In case you missed it, during the credits
of the movie when that song is playing they
show all that Oscorp Tech from Secret Projects,
like the Doctor Octopus harness and the Green
Goblin Glider.
That’s basically who the lineup is.
It’s Green Goblin, Doctor Octopus, Rhino,
Vulture, Kraven the Hunter and Mysterio, that
last one could be the Chameleon.
But I think Mysterio would be more fun.
Based on that Ravencroft scene it looks like
they’ll just use willing test subjects that
are in prison or just total dirtbags looking
for easy power.
They’ll probably stick with the original
comic book characters for each of those personas.
I’m choosing to remain optimistic about
it.
They cast great actors in this movie, but
a lot of it will depend on the script.
Which we won’t see for a long time.
Let me know what you’re thoughts are on
the Sinister Six and Venom movies that are
coming.
If you were confused about the X-Men Scene
at the end.
Here’s what’s going on and why a Fox Movie
was part of a Sony Movie.
Because those are two separate universes.
Spider-Man has nothing to do with X-Men on
a story level.
It’s all because of the director Marc Webb.
He had a contract that was still in force
at Fox when Sony hired him to Direct Amazing
Spider-Man 2.
Fox agreed to let him out of his contract
if Sony would promote Days of Future Past.
Because Sony didn’t have a post-credits
scene for any of their spinoffs ready it just
worked out that with Days of Future Past coming
soon, they opted to use that scene to fulfill
their agreement and make fans happy.
A lot of people feel like if you go to a big
comic book movie like this and you DON’T
get a post-credits scene.
You’ve been cheated out of some money.
So Sony was really happy to have something
to show, even if it wasn’t their own movie.
The X-Men scene didn’t really have any relevant
plot info or spoilery stuff.
It just establishes that Mystique is operating
on her own.
In all the scenes we’ve had so far Magneto
and Professor X are on their own without teams.
So this just helped set that up a little more.
Let me know whether you liked it or just thought
it was out of place.
So in related news, lots of stuff happening
in the next week.
I’m doing a special Godzilla Week with Nerdist
Channel because that movie is coming out in
two weeks.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Most of it will be fun bonus videos and my
review will post after the movie is out.
Right now click here for my breakdown of Star
Wars Episode 7 and click here to learn more
about the Justice League movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!